uno de los episodios de violación de
derechos humanos más graves en la
historia de bogotá es la conclusión de
un informe independiente de 177 páginas
liderado por el ex defensor del pueblo
de colombia carlos negrete ocurrió en
2020 que los días 9 y 10 de septiembre
del 2020 la policía nacional de colombia
reaccionó de una forma desproporcionada
ilegal y apartada el principio de
humanidad en la atención de las
manifestaciones ciudadanas ocurridas en
bogotá y en swat
su actuación causó una masacre la muerte
del taxista javier ordóñez en manos de
dos policías desató la ira de la
ciudadanía contra la violencia policial
el informe calificó que los agentes
protegieron pedazos de cemento a sangre
y fuego una respuesta que dejó 14
muertos 11 en manos de la policía y dos
por civiles armados cientos de agentes y
ciudadanos resultaron heridos de los
cuales 75 fueron por bala 76 comisarías
fueron destruidas al borde de las
lágrimas la alcaldesa claudia lópez
anunció que entregaría el informe a la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos
ofrezco una vez más
perdón a las víctimas
y a mi ciudad el informe recoge
detenciones arbitrarias robos en
comisaría y agresiones de género y
destaca que la represión se focalizó en
jóvenes de clase trabajadora más de un
año después de 427 investigaciones sólo
el 2,5 por ciento ha llegado a la fase
de juicio
procesos contra agentes que se acumulan
con una policía colombiana cuestionada
por utilizar métodos militares contra la
población civil adquiridos para la lucha
contra la guerrilla de las farc el
último episodio fue durante las
protestas iniciadas el pasado 28 de
abril con al menos 25 manifestantes
muertos en manos de la policía según
human rigths watch